لماذا تلقي هذا الخطاب باللغة الإنجليزية
ونفعله بطريقة كبيرة جدًا لأنني
أردت أن يسمع العالم كل ذلك ولا
يوجد سوى بضعة ملايين من
المتحدثين باللغة العبرية وهناك بضعة مليارات في
مكبرات الصوت الخاصة بك وهذا موضوع مهم للغاية
والذي  يتعلق بسعينا لتحقيق
السلام والأمن في الشرق الأوسط
والعالم ، واعتقدت أنه من
المهم أن يسمع أكبر عدد
ممكن من الجمهور
النتائج الدراماتيكية التي وجدناها حول
برنامج الأسلحة النووية السري لإيران ، فالصفقة
التي يتحدث عنها الجميع كانت
مبنية على  حقيقة أن إيران ليس لديها
مثل هذه المواد ولكن إيران أزعجت نفسها
بألم جسيم بعد الاتفاق
النووي وقبله ولكن بعد إخفاء
هذه المعلومات بشكل خاص ، يبدو الأمر وكأنه ترسانة من
المعرفة ليست فقط في أذهان
الأشخاص الذين لديهم ، إنها الحسابات الفعلية
التي يقومون بها.  لقد نفذوا
المخططات والقياسات التي أبقوها
مخفية لأنهم لا يريدون للعالم
أن يعرف ما أظهرته بالأمس أن
لديهم بالفعل هذا الكابابي
قدرة متقدمة جدًا على
تصنيع أسلحة نووية